SAM SHERIDAN: This
is a place that has
seen a lot of human tragedy.
You can bundle it up under
the blanket of a curse,
but you can't deny that
there is something at work
here, some relationship
between West Virginian industry
and a seemingly endless
cycle of calamity.
And since Austin Caperton
won't be providing any answers,
I'm turning to a
trusted old buddy--
science.
So what we do in this
lab is we build stuff.
And we break it to figure
out how to make it stronger.
What a cool job, man.
SAM SHERIDAN: No disaster is
woven into the local folklore
of West Virginia quite like the
collapse of the Silver Bridge.
I think there's
reason behind it.
Yeah.
It just didn't
happen to happen.
They said that the
Moth Man appeared
before the bridge fell.
It's like a legend.
SAM SHERIDAN: Although I'm
fairly certain a flying cryptid
didn't cause this disaster,
the Silver Bridge did collapse
at the exact spot where the
Battle of Point Pleasant
was fought.
And some say that was
the cause of Chief
Cornstalk's dying curse.
So what does science
have to say about
that peculiar coincidence?
MATT HEBOON: This is a
model of the Silver Bridge.
SAM SHERIDAN: Cool.
So the Silver Bridge was
similar to a suspension
bridge except that
the suspension
cables were actually eyebars.
So tell me exactly how
the Silver Bridge failed.
What happened?
There was a flaw.
It was actually located
at the end of the eyebar.
That flaw was extremely
small, and actually
wasn't visible
because it was hidden
under the cap of the pin.
And in this case, the very
small flaw initiated a fracture.
Can you show me what
that would look like?
Yeah.
MATT HEBOON: OK, so we're
going to apply a tension lug,
meaning we're going
to pull on this.
[creaking]
What's this kip?
What is that.
So a kip is 1,000 pounds.
So we're at 0.21
thousand pounds,
or in other words, 22 pounds.
It's incrementally adding load.
This no longer is
contributing at all.
All the force that
was in this component
is now dumped into this one.
SAM SHERIDAN: Right.
In the case of the Silver
Bridge, this happened so fast.
The first one failed
and immediately--
[snap]
Let's-- let's do
it on our model.
MATT HEBOON: OK.
SAM SHERIDAN: And
here's where we smash
stuff in the name of science.
So we're going to simulate
the fracture of the eyebar
by cutting one of
the yellow strings.
[dramatic music] When
one eyebar failed,
there just wasn't enough
capacity in the rest
of the system to resist all of
the weight of the structure,
and therefore the
entire bridge collapsed.
SAM SHERIDAN: So the
Silver Bridge collapses.
What's the way this could
have been prevented?
MATT HEBOON: The original
designs for this bridge
called for a suspension cable.
But they decided to opt
for a less redundant system
with the eyebar chains, which
allowed them to dramatically
reduce the cost.
But it also dramatically reduced
the redundancy in the system.
SAM SHERIDAN: For
those of you at home
who never took an interest
in civil engineering,
let me spell it out for you.
Redundancy equals safety.
So if they hadn't done
this with the lowest bidder,
there's a possibility that that
failure would have happened,
but they would have had enough
redundancy that the bridge
wouldn't have collapsed.
That's right.